you're seeing real police officers
chasing a real human being and shooting
him in the back to accept that fact is
quite terrifying after a series of
high-profile shooters by police officers
across America a crisis is gathering
pace stop killing our keys we don't
fight back they start the war do things
in a year when police shot dead more
than a thousand civilians one man is on
a mission to put an end to the killings
the stakes are very high because right
now policing is at the front page every
newspaper weekly if not daily if I have
to take another individual's life to
protect my life to protect my partner's
life or to protect an innocent citizen
or bystanders life I'll do it
[Music]
I tell myself every day that I might
have to take someone's life
in Camden New Jersey Officer Tyrell bad
B is patrolling the streets of one of
the most dangerous neighborhoods in a
miracle
you don't know what you're going to do
until that particular situation happens
to you
they responded to reports of a
disturbance an abandoned house and block
when you're entering an abandoned
building with so many unknowns you have
to make sure that you're able to protect
yourself because at the end of the day
you have to go home safe last year alone
at least across America shot and killed
more than a thousand people at least one
in 10 shot dead by officers turns out to
be unarmed track marks on his left arm
with the situation's going on at the
present time with officers shooting
citizens and citizens shooting officers
when people see firearms they're smart
enough to know if it's a serious deal we
understand you know you guys are gonna
tell us about being out heads tough
we're gonna let you both go with a
verbal warning these guys they don't
know what they're going in there and
what they're up against I could have you
know reached for something and they
thought there might have been a weapon
you know I could have been shot we have
what is called a 21-foot rule what it
means is that that's the danger zone
right there that you know you you might
have to essentially use your firearm to
stop the threat they wiped police
officer tubes of murdering a black man
the 33 year old officer fires eight
shots at Scott's back slager's case is
the latest in a series of racially
charged police shootings around the
country a white South Carolina State
Trooper opened fire on an unarmed black
man
more outrage in st. Louis police shot
and killed a black man but the cell
phone video appears to tell a different
story
initial reports are questioned after
cell phone video is uncovered
[Music]
what an investigation will determine is
if it could cap County police officer
was justified to shoot the man
now what Wilmington police said was a
clear justified shooting has a community
demanding an investigation there is a
crisis across America it's a dangerous
world out there
but the officers are the professionals
we give them guns we say okay you're
allowed to have a weapon and you're
allowed to use it when it is proper when
you have officer is using their weapon
when it's not proper and people are
getting killed it's a problem in Chicago
the families of african-american men
shot by the police are calling for the
cops to be charged with murder a few
blocks away Chicago PD is hosting the
largest annual gathering of senior
police in this building sharing tips on
how to more effectively increase the
police state in this era of mass
incarceration that we live in that is
destroying black lives and black
communities and in fact not making as
safe as they say but actually putting
our lives in more days
there's never been a time where there
has been trust between the black
community and policing because there has
never been a time where the police have
not been violent and not particularly
targeted black Americans the men and
women in charge of the country's nine
hundred thousand armed offices are
assembling the policing crisis in
America has reached a critical point
every day you risk your lives so that
the rest of us don't have to but you
know as well as I do that the tensions
in some communities the feeling that law
enforcement isn't always applied fairly
those sentiments don't just come out of
nowhere we all have a responsibility to
do something about it because it's part
of our our legacy there are an estimated
300 million guns in America in Richmond
California one of the most violent
cities in the country officers seized
hundreds of illegal firearms
each year as years were the stuff of
Hira never needs to play guns in America
right that's the manufacturers don't
stop making them do that
see how stronger him Oh
packages ago chief Allred Brown has
policed a violent streets of Richmond
for more than three decades this is a
closet where blood-soaked items can hang
to dry he now leads a force of 200 sworn
officers you don't get to make mistakes
so out in the field it's real and
there's really no second chances
this carries 30 rounds where my gun only
carries 8 if there's a bad guy over
there and I'm trying to have a distance
shot and I want to have a scope on it
site they can shooter longer range much
more accurately officer enrico cosa has
been a cop game for 8 years
we run towards the bullets when people
are running away that's basically our
job that's what we get paid to do you
can never be prepared or trim perfectly
for every situation you can just be
prepared and trained to the best of your
ability to handle the situation if
somebody says you're not scared like I
said they're lying to you I did scared a
couple times a day so they can cover
more ground
the majority of police officers in
America ride solo it's a brotherhood we
all take care of each other we all want
to make sure everybody goes home whether
it's to their significant others to
their family we're dealing with the
shitbirds
society that want not only wanted to
find create crime but also harm or kill
police officers at least a pulled over a
vehicle driving with no lover plates
these officers have started wearing body
cameras to capture every interaction
with the public you guys make sure you
got no weapons just strange what
happened ok why is that mr. seeders the
only thing that you know that's gonna
occur every day is you're gonna come to
work and you're gonna put on your
uniform and that's it you don't know if
you're gonna get shot you don't know if
you're gonna have to shoot somebody or
use force or take another individual's
life give me a fair Tyrell
would you rather have me on your bed
21 he's called gun - sit
it's a Glock 23 and I'll tell you it's
got its loaded so it's ready to fire
right now and SOLAS he sued three black
people we're first put on the lights
he's just trying to make it a racist
thing he's trying to say we pull them
over simply because he's black that's
the biggest thing is that everything
that's made into a racial issue hey the
cops are racist the cops are doing this
the cops are doing that well if you
notice I'm not black I'm Mexican he's
not black he's Asian he's not white
either though so it's not like we pulled
him over strictly because they're black
oh is that why is there a war on the
point it doesn't make any sense
you're getting to the point where
officers are getting in trouble for just
simply doing their job they're being
called you know racist or the you know
heavy-handed you know they just want to
beat up people or they're just you know
crooks with a gun whatever you know yeah
I've heard it all you're getting a point
to where officers are just gonna do
absolutely nothing they're not going to
go out and just make car stops or stop
people on the corners that are selling
drugs they're just gonna sit in their
car wait for a call to come out and
respond to that call and they're gonna
do absolutely nothing else I mean one
gun off the street is one gun off the
street one less gun out there to hurt us
or it's not gonna stop them criminals
from getting guns at all so even even
the gun laws are not gonna stop
criminals you try and make people turn
in guns good people are gonna turn into
guns but the criminals aren't obviously
so when you take the guns away from good
people criminals are still gonna have a
gun gun so the good people are not gonna
be able to protect themselves from the
criminal
[Music]
it seems that it was not politically
convenient for the public to be aware of
the truth of this instance at the time
so the police department were trying to
cover up a Barrie any of the proof or
the video of this horrific brutal murder
you
he firmly believed that he was in fear
for his life and he was concerned about
the life of his fellow officers attorney
Dan Herbert knows everyone will soon see
the dashcam video of what happened that
night on Pulaski road when laQuan
McDonald armed with a knife and
reportedly under the influence of drugs
was shot and killed he says it will show
an officer simply following police
guidelines about the use of deadly force
against knife wielding suspects laQuan
McDonald was a 17 year old who had been
a ward of the state so in and out of the
foster system for much of his life I
believe there was a call for a
disturbance for a young man and and he
had a knife at the time and was walking
in the street
and the police pull it up on him and he
continued walking and was walking away
from him and a police officer shot him
down to the ground shot him 16 times and
then as he was lying dying shot into his
body
there is this 21-foot rule which
essentially talks about how a an
individual is a significant threat hue
to a police officer when they are within
that 21 foot boundary when you're
talking about how police operate there's
formal rules and those informal rules
okay so the formal rules you read the
regulations and everything and you
listen then you go to informal rules
Trump formal rules informal rules are
like hey you learn all of this stuff in
a car you learn all the stuff in the
Academy and get in a car with someone
and say listen kid let me just tell you
something you are you familiar with the
21 foot rule is oh what's that well this
guy you know came up with the science
said if you're within 21 feet they get
within 21 feet it's you or them with a
reactionary gap of about one foot or
less it's impossible for you to react
quickly enough to even touch your
holstered sidearm once the attack begins
at about five feet the average officer
can't even get his sidearm on holstered
tests with hundreds of officers revealed
that in most cases a minimum reactionary
gap of twenty-one feet is required to
react and deliver at least two rounds
and to have enough time to move out of
the attackers path what the 21 foot rule
has done in the United States in some
places I won't say everywhere but in
some places it has been like I've heard
you know one time in New York City it
was considered by some you know a
license to to shoot someone that if they
came within that distance it's either
you or them it's one point two seconds
they can get to you so it's like taking
on those things either formal or
informal and knocking them down
Chuck Wexler is a former hostage
negotiator with the Boston PD he now
leads a team focused on putting an end
to the epidemic of shoots Chuck has
discovered the unarmed police officers
in some parts of the UK routinely face
violent suspects are the knives and
sharp weapons baton he used a baton
there look how many there must be 20 and
they just surround it with their shields
Chuck's it's hard to reduce police use
of deadly force but it will involve
retrained almost a million armed
officers when you think about you know
what we're trying to do here getting
Americans to get their head around this
different approach do you think is that
gonna be a hard sell in policing he
believes the answer may lie free and a
half thousand miles away
chuckles kovitch 20 flat police chiefs
from major departments across America to
travel with him discovered good morning
yeah I'm Alan Gibson from six Granger
thanks to me how you doing hi George
Allen Gibson from high school and they
say hi good morning strangely enough I
don't know why no one said no but I
don't know that they would have said yes
had we not had this past year in other
words had there not been one incident
after another after another after
another you know I'm not so well chuckle
you know it's very interesting you're
going to Scotland but you know I've got
I got a major I got a major Boston
Police Department to run or New York or
Chicago or you know wherever Los Angeles
all the places they carry Scotland
sounds interesting I'd love to come but
I'm I'm very busy
they dropped what they had to do it's
that significant
they dropped what they had to do to be
here
now someone's got their hands in the
pocket why do we need to resolve that
sergeant Jim young trains hundreds of
new recruits each year at Scotland's
police academy that's a slightly
different boys proceed to pass yes buddy
oh wait a minute wait a minute
some departments do have a 21-foot rule
with all due respect they do so whether
you like to say it's a rule or not it's
become our whole use of force and that's
really what's been the debate for the
last year the fact is you got to base it
on the behavior of the person with the
knife if the person with the knife is
just sitting in a chair you know holding
the knife and and I walk up you know
within 5 feet of that person the person
didn't approach me I approached that
person so you know that's we're talking
to cops now about you know let's let's
not create the moment where deadly force
has to be used
it's Friday night in Glasgow chuckles
jointed sergeant Jim young on a
fact-finding mission with a city centre
night shift
officer additional events are taking
place just ask used to be able you
betcha one but any suspicious people
packages or anything so it's a special
behavior
weekend yeah I'm ready let's go sergeant
Jim is supervisor delayed shift to the
central Glasgow he's be able to police
for 20 years
they were spotted two reports of an
altercation
he's kicking the front door and it was
an allegation that animefan
they get here quickly and I think you
know they started talking and they
outnumber
the recent release of dashcam footage
showing a teenager being gunned down by
a Chicago PD officer has shaken American
police into his core it's hard to watch
it's hard to comprehend to see a
situation like that unfold it's it's
gut-wrenching but that's why we're here
we can do better
you looking there maybe the two stables
are policing you know if you look at
that made it can stay off leasing it's
very authoritative there's a difference
of having English 3 and offered a stable
we are by your author and people you're
shouting at them when even after that
yes start though law you can you can
adjust yeah yes your communications to
suit the way he's running this guy's
well he's running after him
back in Chicago
following a dashcam release tensions are
growing they disavow these lives so
highly that one cop is worth the same as
a hundred daily
but then you can't stop the revolution
[Music]
I don't think it is an accident mistake
or incorrect for police to feel that
they are in their war because they are
[Music]
another dashcam video of a Chicago cop
shooting a young black male
four officers went to the 5300 block of
King Drive at about midnight they saw
man matching the description of a gunman
and went after him what's fascinating is
from the police department is that they
first went on the news that night
because they wanted to control the media
they wanted to control the story police
say the man pointed a gun in the
officers direction during the chase then
one of the officers fired the man was
pronounced dead at a hospital police say
they recovered a weapon at the scene
somebody was dying before your eyes to
accept that fact is quite terrifying the
police immediately said that night that
Rani turned 22 weapon at the police
officer the police officer feared for
his life and for the lives of others and
he fired his weapon did Chicago Police
Department is retracted the statement
that Ronald Johnson turned and pointing
the gun but they still claimed that
firearm was found in his head
the reason why I'm here because it is
very important for me to clear my son
name because I want to know why was my
son
cute and y'all got on TV and lad I say
he had a gun in his hand
then we're approaching the intersection
and the street where Ronald Johnson is
shot back
as we get to the corner of 53rd and
Martin Luther King Drive Roni turns the
corner and heads to the right officer
Hernandez unmarked police Corps arrives
at an angle as Ronnie is running full
speed he enters the street officer
Hernandez gets out of his car he draws
his weapon he takes aim after taking a
few steps towards Ronald Johnson's back
two gunshots strike Ronnie in the back
of the right knee one strike some in the
back shoulder and travels through his
body severs his jugular vein and comes
out through his eye socket Ronald
Johnson was murdered right here but he
makes it across the street he staggers
he falls into the grass and this is
where his body lay they shot him in the
back as he was running away
end of story and you can't do that but
he did they then covered it up because
they're saying they recovered a gun from
his right hand and if he didn't have a
gun in his hand as he was running there
can't be a gun in his right hand unless
the police put it there he was a mama's
boy
oh mama boy he's a mama's boy but he's
still my baby to lose somebody on the
streets of Chicago being gunned down by
the people that supposed to serve and
protect you
that's a hateful crime that was real
hateful but it ain't over yet
it's a long ways from being over no
mother should have to bury their child
let them live so they get old and down
there on why they got to get murdered
[Music]
Dorothee hose has been fighting for
justice for our son Ronald Johnson for
more than a year now
we demand Cook County State's Attorney
Anita Alvarez fire and charge those CPD
officer who murder enemy
in Glasgow the chase is over Chuck and
the offices have safely apprehended a
pickpocket
I think in the back of every police
officers mind there's always that key
there's always that kind of element to
they could have and it's what if some
box you know you could have a weapon on
them most weapons obviously we deal with
in Glasgow and could be you know they
can extend from knuckle dusters to
knives to you know you name it it could
be anything thoughts but again over the
coming days these Scottish offices will
demonstrate how to tackle armed suspects
without resorting to deadly force you
have to say to the sceptics look you
know as far as guns is concerned America
has a very different situation and we
did not come to Scotland to ask Scotland
to help us deal with guns police
Scotland officers are trained to step
back from armed suspects and use their
vehicles for cover in many parts of
America things would be handled
differently somebody picks up a rock or
brick let's get it thrown into we will
probably pull a gun and tell you to drop
the weapon
it's the proportionality how would
society over here think about you
shooting someone with a rock they would
not accept it when they're talking about
the preservation really on the suspects
life and that is not as high up on our
list when we're exactly when we are
faced with a level of aggression in
America that I don't think they see here
in level of violence in America that we
see here and the complete disrespects
that type of policing so I think when
you say preservation of life it is
everybody's life owls has a pecking
order I'm just being honest the way
change happens in police departments is
you get a group of police departments
like this and then they start doing it
and and they you know people see start
to learn some of this of what we're
attempting to do here it's completely
opposite of American thinking
[Music]
how is it that you know 98% of their
officers are unarmed and yet they still
carry out the duty of enforcing law and
bringing offenders to justice and how is
it that we even with the armed officers
that the instances of an
officer-involved shooting is such a rare
[Applause]
clearly in Scotland their entire model
is built on every decision coming back
to their code of ethics which includes
human rights that's a foreign concept to
us not that we don't value people or
human rights we're not terrible people
who want to do bad things it's just that
we're not our culture is not designed to
think like this result is both parties
go home safely that's huge that's huge
the cops look terrific the cops they
risk their lives to resolve something in
a win-win situation and that to me was
the Epiphany
what's happening and I'm growing
increasingly weary as a police chief
it's explaining to my County executives
how the hell is it we could fire 28
rounds between two and three officers
and the guy has a remote control in his
pocket a chair leg one case a bar so at
the same time my son's on the job
oh the kid busted up scarred up out of
work lose a job died nobody's gonna die
by my having better effective
communication more strategies tactical
strategies to deal with someone in a
volatile situation nobody's gonna die
from from learning de-escalation
techniques and so there's a hot and I'm
forgetting half of things but but
there's a whole host of things that we
picked up here that's where we can start
and it starts us in the right direction
we have to instill in our troops that I
want to put policies in place we're
going to train at the escalate we're
going to make sure that you're safe and
by ensuring that you my officers report
off safely at night you're going to
shoot at the public reports all safely
that's something what do you guys say
whether it a beep or Oh safely to jail
or to a mental institution or however it
works they're going to do our best to
get him to that position back in
Richmond California the offices are
responding to reports of a man with a
bat
Richmond police do not move don't move
get down on the ground down on the
ground keep your hands where we can see
them explain everything in just a second
sir
oh it's cap gun the weapon is a toy boss
yeah yeah look at that painted black eye
compared to this and it's not it's a
pretty good similarity if you don't know
the difference yeah you know what
destroy this for me and like if you run
into somebody in the dark like that and
he was let's say he decides to turn
around on an officer with that I mean we
don't have the time to think hey is that
real or is that fake we think he's gonna
try and kill us with that and that that
would cause us to shoot him and possibly
kill him and then come to find out later
on once it's all done if it was a fake
gun but we don't know that offices here
go from cool to cool for up there tell
our shift they never know what to expect
he came to the front door with the
hatchet in his hand and then threatened
the cops
apparently he's schizophrenic and
barricaded himself the hatchet premise
shows that three officers and a sergeant
respond
[Music]
you
it's more than a year since Dorothy and
her legal team started their campaign to
have the officer who killed her son one
charge of murder Oh God there is no gun
in his hand and you can say that there's
a gun in his hands you know I think the
video is speak for yourself I think it
is grainy I think you see him running I
think you see him running at full speed
I think he does you know they've been
caught in their lives already
although Dorothy's lawyer believes
Ronald was wrongfully shot dead there
are still no evidence to support his
theory that a police fly the weapon the
night of the killing
we're still hoping that the feds will
come in and charge this guy they're
awaiting the result of the state
attorney's investigation
the RC FL processed a still frame from
that video at our request we were trying
to determine if there was visual proof
of the weapon in Johnson's hands this is
the result of their work
after the shooting several officers ran
over to Ronald Johnson and indicated
they observe the weapon in his hand
officer Hernandez later secured it in
the trunk of a sergeants vehicle a drop
of blood to the gun match Ronald's DNA
the original police report others didn't
know you know what there might have been
a motive actually we've been seeing this
more and more a certain spokesperson who
would go out and say things at the sight
of a police shooting I wouldn't rely on
any of those things is there an object
in his hand I submitted there's an
object in his hand yeah are CFL
they don't give it a penny I don't I
don't know no I don't believe so based
on the totality for the evidence in this
case and with the very very careful
analysis of the laws of the state of
Illinois
it is our extermination that no criminal
charges will be filed against officer
Hernandez in connection with the
shooting death of Ronald Johnson they
say when Ronald fell grass got stuck at
a gun high and one witness foot they
heard him cooking a gun earlier that day
okay the fight is just starting you know
that right okay so I'm gonna do my thing
you want to go in there with me okay ask
you some questions you're ready follow
me the Chicago Police Department issued
a statement that Ronald Johnson turned
and pointed a gun at officer Hernandez
and in fearing for his safety and the
safety of others he fired and Nita
belittles that but that is a statement
from the Chicago Police Department there
is no proof there is nothing to tie
Ronald Johnson to anything to do with
that gun despite her lawyers belief that
the gun was planted on Ronald after he
was shot the State Attorney's
investigation has concluded that the
shooting was lawful
police officers in Richmond California
are responding to a 9 1 1 called
yesterday the suspect threatened to kill
his neighbor with a hatchet throw it
through the window back up I want to
talk to them in the window and I want to
be is you know personable and is you
know non-threatening as possible but the
same time I'm not gonna take an axe to
my head
as part of their new UK stout
de-escalation tactics the officers are
ordered to withdraw to avoid using
deadly force the new approach is not
popular with all the offices just under
the circumstances in it's not gonna be
nice but on the flip side - it's kind of
like we're just letting these two
neighbors that live within 10 feet of
this crazy guy back into your abs well
it's not in the fact that if he hurts
the neighbors what if he goes crazy
again goes outside hurts someone else
even if he just hurts it so they kill
him it's still like please didn't do the
job
apparently he's schizophrenic and
barricaded himself yesterday with the
arms a hatchet premise show the three
officers and a sergeant to respond
like 105 of all civilians killed by
police officers he suffers from mental
illness
just walked across the kitchen window
it's completely quite open okay so we
have an access point here's why we're
going in case things go bad is he's very
terrorizing the neighbors he's already
been trying to be dangerous we left him
on last night and he's still acting
crazy it's all marui [ __ ] and then
it's gonna get worse and worse worse
progressively the officers decide to
take action I know you can hear me come
on it's the right thing to do that's all
I want you to do man come out of your
room with your hands up
we're going to somebody else's home so
who knows where he has weapons hidden in
the house
both his hands
the ant Kazami didn't resist or anything
like that you know which is a great
result considering his actions earlier
either today and then yesterday pretty
violent so it's nice like that we didn't
fight us
he had knives and a lot of edged weapon
placed around his house which is common
with people that suffer from paranoia
schizophrenia did you ever know what
he's gonna do tomorrow might be the day
that he snaps and says to chop up
somebody instead of a door if a suspect
an armed person with this type of edged
weapon were to present it to an officer
in a threatening manner he could be
killed we can we could shoot the person
lawfully talk to the psychologist okay
I'm sorry 23
officers made entry into the residence
through an unlocked rear sliding door
the hatchet used was seized as evidence
when the suspect was taken into custody
without incident in Chicago the
government has stepped in to reform the
police department I'm here to announce
that the Department of Justice has
opened an investigation into whether the
Chicago Police Department has engaged in
a pattern or practice of violations of
the Constitution or federal law after a
job well done back in Richmond officer
Mel Gaza is called in to see the chief
this commendation is being presented to
you as an acknowledgement of the bravery
and courage you displayed by your
actions the US and the statements in I
hope that the you know society realizes
that police are here for a reason and
we're not the bad guys Dorothy continues
her struggle for justice for her son
Ronald when his father passed it was
just one
once you get old enough to understand
what death means and I'll be able to
tell him like you know your father was
killed by a Chicago police and chuckle
his team have launched their new
training program to hundreds of police
forces across America it's about time
that we kind of step up and this is our
chance this is our opportunity and and
it's a crisis right but it's also you
know a chance to do the right thing
all right say your daddy's I love you
all right so see you later
you
[Music]